so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you how it is
that you can graph this now as we've
done
in everything in graphing the complex
plane right there are hard ways and easy
ways to do this right
now i'm going to show you the most
efficient path it requires
more visual intuition and geometric
reasoning
but what it avoids is just a mess of
error prone and very inefficient algebra
okay i will show you that method just
not here
but for now let's have a think about
this equation and what it gives us right
so for starters argo z minus one on z
plus one immediately you know there are
two points
two reference points that you can put
onto your complex plane that sort of the
rest of the shape we've built off what
are those two points
plus or minus one on the real axis right
so you go ahead if you haven't already
and pop those
in so i'm just gonna as my scale that's
all right
plus minus one these are my reference
points then you look over to the right
hand side you see it's pi on four
right so you're like pi on four that's a
an acute angle it's an acute angle which
gives me what kind of arc
big one a little one uh it's a major arc
right a big arc
small angle big arc so therefore i know
i'm going to have either
something big up here or something big
down here now i've kind of cheated
and shown you by the way i've drawn my
complex plane i already know which one
i'm going for the top or the bottom how
did i know
that it would be at the top what piece
of information told me that again
yeah very good i go from the numerator
to the denominator this is one
and this represents minus negative one
right so i'm going to go from one
anti-clockwise round to negative one
okay
so at that point maybe you were
confident enough
to eyeball an arc like that but there's
a lot of information
still missing off of here right i've got
this and this
and then i'm like what what else i got
i've got no cartesian equation
uh and that's because i've got no center
i've got a radius okay so
this is where i said you need some
geometric reasoning to help you okay
now for example i'm interested in
finding that point up there for sure but
it's going to take me some reason to get
here
there rather so what i want to put on
here is some extra bits of construction
that will help me
okay for starters i'll use a different
color here just to highlight it for you
i'm going to go ahead and draw the angle
up to that point
standing on uh in this segment i should
say right
now because of the equation over here
what's that angle
what's the size of it this whole angle
is pi on four
okay now for reasons to become clear in
a second i'm actually not going to put
the whole angle
i'm going to put half of it which i know
sounds weird but i can do that because
of the symmetry of my
shape and i should say you're like but
what if it's not symmetrical okay
we're going to give you equations that
make this not impossible to find
if you have weirdo looking oblique arcs
like this it really is completely
impractical right
so we'll give you something that makes
it relatively easy so i'm gonna put pi
on eight
up here okay now the reason why it's
useful to me is because
knowing roughly the center of the circle
should be i don't know i'm just going to
eyeball it around
there right i can do a whole bunch of
constructions that are really going to
help me here for instance
if i'd done it roughly yeah i'm okay
with that if you have a look at this
triangle that i've just created
over here on the left hand side right
what kind of triangle is that
that's an isosceles triangle right
because if i'm saying that's roughly
where the center is
then these two are radii right so
equal sides are opposite equal
angles see that it's part 8 over there
and i've done this trick a couple of
times right this angle here and this
angle here
are interior angles that are opposite
i'll just use another color now here it
is they're opposite
this exterior angle see that so
therefore
the exterior angle equals the sum of the
opposite to interior angles so what's
this angle
pi over 4 right which means that down
here because it's these are the
coordinate axis that's right angles
down here you've got what have you got
another isosceles triangle
right and thankfully because i know back
to this color
because i know this distance here which
is
which is one that means i know this
distance here
also one so now i have coordinates right
this point here in fact i'm not going to
put brackets and this point here because
it's one unit above
the real axis in complex terms i would
call that
i you're happy with that all right now
that i know that
i can also work out a whole bunch of
other things right this is one this is
one what's the radius
it's root two through two which means
and this is where i was going right
to get up to this point up here i have
to go from
this point here which is one unit above
and i've got to go another root two
right so therefore this would be one
plus root two
lots of i because i'm in the imaginary
direction okay
can you tell me the equation of the
circle from this
what do you think x squared
because our normal circles we start at
the origin and then we shift
but i haven't shifted horizontally
anywhere i'd have shifted vertically
though
this is um yeah the center the center
has gone up one unit
so it's y minus one
squared and then what's on the right
hand side two because that's
the square of the radius which we've
already established as route 2. makes
sense
now i'm going to stop there like i said
there is a long and awkward way to
algebraically do this i'll show you
but i hope if you look at that you'll be
convinced i don't want to go there
if i can possibly avoid it and the
geometric thinking is actually the main
thing we're looking for
want to add anything mrs elise not about
that okay
um a manual question if i use the circle
i need to quote like the rules
like center angles is twice and any
inscribed angle substantial right there
sure so um there's a bunch of different
ways to do this question
i've deliberately avoided using some of
the circle geometry properties
that i know you haven't covered for like
a long time but if you're going to use
them
you're going to tell me why right so the
short answer to your question is yes
oh yeah for the the cartesian equation
do we also also have to include y
greater than zero ah
okay so do you need to include y is
greater
than not including zero to make this
correct okay
um the short answer is in this case
absolutely like i don't have the whole
circle down here do i
however i do want to point out if you
just come back and look at some of these
arcs that we've drawn before
right you see how they're off at an
angle they're what we call oblique right
which
just means offered at angle right you
can't simply say oh x is less than this
y is greater than that right it doesn't
quite work because you don't have a nice
horizontal cut off right you'd actually
have to use a couple of different
restrictions to tell you which part of
the domain that it is
but generally this equation and this
diagram
they are my answer right you can see
unambiguously from here which part i'm
including which part i'm not
so make sense